sam raimi's dr strange and the
multiverse of madness that is a dream
come true
[Music]
i got a call from my agent saying that
kevin feige and the marvel team were
looking for a director
for the new doctor strange movie and i
was a big fan of the first one it was
really intelligent and interesting so
when that offer came and i thought this
would be a really good challenge ready
to go
[Music]
sam is such a lovely human being and
obviously he's standing in this industry
and this genre in particular is
legendary as it should be
sam has become known for this
terrorizing cinema experience
he's creating as much tension as
possible for the audience just ready for
them to have that jump scare moment
and that was always where we were headed
with the sequel to doctor strange
knowing that we wanted to explore the
mind-bending frightening side the
multiverse
we need your help with what
what do you know about the multiverse
telling the story is such a gigantic
endeavor and there's a lot of
dimensionalized visuals that we use in
telling that story
we shot it with an eye toward that so i
think it's going to be a very exciting
experience to go to 3d
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you